aux etats unis
poursuivent leurs activités c'est un
choix qu'ils ont fait de vivre
aux étudiants et donc ils vont retourner
chez eux mais évidemment et déjà depuis
2002 ans ils ont annoncé qu'il ne
voulait plus faire
d'activités real tels que le prince
harry les avait fait avant donc là
maintenant c'est les tâches du nouveau
prince de galles ils vont avoir de plus
grandes responsabilités
et
il va continuer à faire les grands
voyages à l'extérieur
du pays comme si se faisait avant et on
peut s'attendre aussi que
les la princesse anne la princesse
royale
continue elle aussi à faire des visites
royales et le frère du roi charles
prince édouard va aussi mettre la main à
la tâche alors que je vous écoute je
regarde attentivement ces images on voit
du mouvement au balcon et sl j'ai un peu
l'impression puis corrigé mois peut-être
que si vous le savez peut-être plus que
moi j'ai l'impression que le roi
charleroi où nous entrons j'ai
l'impression qu'on sait prévoir qu'elle
se voit
on va voir quelle que c'est
on voit très bien donc il ya du
mouvement et
il va certainement celui cette foule qui
devant le palais de buckingham convoi on
voit l'étendard royal
l'étendard du souverain qui est qui
flotte sur le palais donc ce singh veut
dire que c'est le signal que le roi est
dans est rendu à buckingham palace parce
que dès qu'ils quittent le drapeau ce
drapeau la bbc se remuant bien ça c'est
l'étendard royal ce n'est pas le le
drapeau l'union jack c'est différent
d'accord se sait se déplacer le drapeau
personnel souverain alors c'est le
drapeau pour dire où il est alors des
kits vos clients par l'ess le drapeau
vote vont être retirés on va peut être
remettre union jack en berne mais si le
prince charles revient à bocognano on va
enlever le new jack et on va remettre
son étendard qui va lui flotter athema
parce que il est présent sur place c'est
un excellent indice parce que tout à
l'heure il était du côté du palais st
james à la regarder sur 2,3 alors
l'étendard devait ici à ce moment là oui
donc ça nous indique qu'il est à
l'intérieur du palais sera alors comme
il va quitter fin probable ce soir ou
demain pour aller faire certains sa
tournée des quatre composantes du du
royaume uni alors l'étendard royal ne
sera neuf l'autre plus sur le palais
parce que il est absent du palais et
c'est pendant le le saas et le signal où
on sait où il le roi avec ce symbole et
si vous vous rappelez lors du décès de
diana princesse de galles il y avait eu
beaucoup de co2 de commentaires sur le
fait qu'ils n'avaient pas de drapeau qui
flottait sur le palais de buckingham et
la reine est à balmoral donc le drapeau
ne pouvait pas flotter mais ce sont des
petits détails qui font que il ya
plusieurs personnes qui qui ne voyais
pas la différence et les parfois les les
commentaires vont bon train mais l'eau
comme ça que c'est extrêmement important
de vous avoir ces précieux donc d'avoir
un spécialiste comme vous de la
monarchie britannique a investi dans ces
moments là pour vous ça va être très
spécial aussi de suivre sans doute
pour moi que c'est un événement
évidemment historique et de pouvoir le
vivre comme ça
et d'avoir accès au temps d'information
s'est fait fort apprécié on voit donc la
foule à l'extérieur on voit aussi des
dignitaires qu'on avait aperçu un peu
plus tôt ensemble dans la salle privée
du palais saint james qui ont assisté à
cette cérémonie de proclamation
officielle du roi charles ii 3 vous vous
reconnaissez d'anciens premiers
ministres
britanniques dont boris johnson
notamment donc on a vu également les
strass qui était présente et puis
différents dignitaires et son 200
membres du conseil privé avoir possédé
situe à clamecy oui parce que le lieu
plus de gens qui sont dans le conseil de
vie sont environ 1700 mais il y en a eu
200 kg ont participé ce matin à ce
conseil
d'accession prendre avec quelques
membres de la famille également on a vu
camilla la reine consort également le
prince william comme il était à ses
côtés
regardez un peu comment ça se déroule
parce qu'on n'a pas toutes les étapes on
n'a pas nous l'aurait récit minute par
minute alors que le protocole est très
très précis et donc on regarde ensemble
on vit le moment donc procession
peut-être qu'on se rend à l'autre
endroit où il y aura cette proclamation
dans trois bars que c'est c'est
r
le centre de londres le violon dans la
cité
qui sait le quartier des affaires et
cela qui va voir
la proclamation librement au public
nouveau roi charles iii
on sent beaucoup le on voit que les gens
sont fort intéressé par ce qui se
déroule devant eux et très respectueux
il n'y a pas de
on sent que les gens veulent participer
mais d'une façon extrêmement sobre et en
harmonie avec tous ceux qui se pensent
sont de longues de longues heures
pourrait publier qui est présent
peut-être même de longues journées j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya des gens qui sont
là depuis presque plus de 24 heures oui
est fort probable que lorsque
le jour de noël 19 il va certainement
avoir des gens qui vont commencer à
s'installer le long du parcours 2 ou
même peut-être trois jours avant pour
être certaine d'avoir un bon endroit
soir
voir le déroulement de 2 to le le
protocole et les
défilés qui va entourer la cérémonie
pour être aux premières loges finalement
temps dans cette procession donc on a
parlé de de cette foule qui attend la
proclamation publique la foule qui était
tout près du palais saint-james ce matin
long mais on était au palais de
buckingham et donc on les entrées de se
déplacer pour aller faire cette
proclamation publique qui devrait avoir
lieu me dit ans dans un peu plus d'une
minute au tour de 6h30 très exactement
et depuis le début on semble suivre
l'horaire de façon prodigieuse mais ça
c'est ce que les si c'est ça qui est
avec la famille royale lors ce qu'ils
ont des cérémonies de ce type il se
prépare tellement d' avance tout est
calculé à la minute près c'est la même
chose quand ils font des voyages
officiels à l'extérieur vous avez vu au
printemps lorsque le prêcheur l'époque
il est venu
il a passé seulement quelques jours mais
tout s'est déroulé de façon tellement
tous couler très très facilement mais le
voyage avait été prévu quelqu'un qui est
venu une équipe qui est venue avant
quelques mois avant pour voir tous les
endroits qu'ils étaient pour revisiter
calculer combien temps ça prend pour
aller d'un endroit à l'autre
s'ils s'arrêtent pour parler on ajoute
quelques minutes alors tout est préparé
d'avancé donc c'est pour ça que quand tu
es des cérémonies comme ça ça se déroule
bien parce qu'on la pratique et c'est se
sert monial l'aca a été pratiquée
pendant plusieurs années surtout
maintenant que la reine elisabeth avancé
un âge et bien on le faisait souvent
l'été c'est un attrait touristique de
voir qu'on se pratique pour
pour ce type d'événement surtout qu'on
sait que cette cérémonie doit avoir lieu
normalement maximum 24 heures après la
mort d'un de souverains étant donné
l'heure du décès de la reine
autour de 18h par locales ont finalement
on a donné un peu plus de temps pour
pouvoir faire cette cérémonie ce matin
mais quand même c'est moins de deux
jours mouvementés le décès les helvètes
alors à la profonde dans préparée et
répétée à en amour alors on voit les
grenadiers de la gamme qui
[Musique]
et on peut voir les derrière et
des reliques du passé si je peux dire
avec ses à ses hommes en armure
d'autrefois avec les grands
sa date d'un peu de l'époque du
moyen-age avec leur leur ep pas une épée
meilleur bâton oui tout juste d'être
toujours derrière
[Musique]
c
une aide
je vous rappelle mesdames messieurs
qu'on suit ce matin cette cérémonie
officielle de proclamation du roi
charles iii tout a commencé vers 5h ce
matin donc c'était au palais saint james
à l'intérieur du palais avec ce comité
qui procédait à cette cérémonie de
proclamation alors qu'effectivement
charles est devenu roi automatiquement
leur vie des faits de sa mère lui fait
partie du protocole d'y aller avec cette
cérémonie solennelle de proclamation on
a entendu charles iii qui a prêté
serment et également le comité cette
déclaration publique qui a été fait en
dix ans le prince charles est maintenant
notre seul roi ce qu'a déclaré le
conseil un peu plus tôt ce matin avant
qu'ils puissent avant qu'il prenne la
parole oui et c'est de cette cérémonie
la date évidemment
presque
à l'époque du moyen âge ou
évidemment c'était beaucoup plus à
l'époque même le roi était élu mais
rapidement on a décidé d'avoir ce type
de cérémonie pour vraiment que tout le
monde connaisse c'est qui le nouveau
bois et
la tradition au fait que cette cérémonie
heures à perdurer le jusqu'à nos jours
jean no 3 qui hérite d'un empire qui est
qui est moindre que celui de sa mère
avec des pays en moins qui font partie
du commonwealth
quel sera le principal défi à votre avis
pour le roi charles ii très bien je
pense que le roi va vouloir le concept
ce qu'est le commonwealth
c'est une organisation que lorsque la
reine elizabeth et hervé de notre on
avait seulement sept pays qui en faisait
partie maintenant on est à 54 55 donc
mais il y en a qui veulent commencer à
se retirer de ne plus avoir
le souverain angleterre comme roy donc
il ya des modifications qui doivent être
apportées à ce à ceux qui le
commonwealth et je crois que le roi va
c'est un des éléments qui vont vouloir
travailler avec toute une équipe de voir
comment ce le commonwealth en lui-même
comment l'ensemble de ces pays là
peuvent modifier leur façon d'être tout
en restant unis et si certains pays dans
l'ailé les 15 au royaume qui veulent
ne plus avoir leur poids d'angleterre
comme
s'ouvrait comme ici au canada parce que
c'est charles le roi charles qui est
nôtre qui est le chef donne alors ils
vont essayer peut-être de trouver des
façons de faire des procédures qui va
permettre ce changement là mais que ça
se fasse en douceur que ça se fasse pas
d'une façon mais évidemment c'est
quelque chose qu'on va voir dans les
prochains six mois cd c'est une
organisation
une grande organisation donc on va
prendre le temps de s'asseoir d'étudier
chaque facette et comment on peut
ajuster changer certains règlements pour
permettre à ceux qui veulent quitter
le fait d'être d'avoir le roi
d'angleterre comme chef d'état le plus
la faire en douceur tout en restant avec
les cominois lorsque je crois que tout
ce qui entoure la commune wav la presse
le roi charles va votre travail et avoir
à trouver des solutions évidemment
le pays dans une crise présentement donc
ils vont essayer de deux ils vont
certainement conseiller la nouvelle
première ministre
ça veut pas dire qu'elles vont suivre à
la lettre ce qui va lui dire mais il va
quand même pouvoir connaissant déjà très
bien la situation il va pouvoir donner
son opinion en privé évidemment et
discuter d'ordre
d'économie de
tout le côté social et voir comment on
peut trouver de meilleures solutions
pour aider les britanniques ça fait
énormément de changements l'espace de
quelques jours au royaume uni avec les
strass nouvelle première ministre cette
semaine le décès de la reine et j'avais
2 ce jeudi
et maintenant la proclamation officielle
du roi charles iii je vous rappelle
qu'on suit tout ça en direct
6h36 maintenant on va écouter pour voir
comment ça se déroule en ce moment
- est-ce que c'est extrêmement
silencieux wee toutes ces étapes même
les spectateurs
on ne pense que l'impression qu'ils
[Musique]
quichotte entre eux mais qu' on en voit
que tout le monde est au à l'affût de ce
qui va se dérouler en
sont les membres du conseil d'accession
du conseil privé que vous allez voir
[Musique]
le conseil d'accession qui a reconnu son
talent son nouveau l'humour souveraine
que ça se passe essentiellement fonds
privés j'ai mentionné avec deux avec des
dignitaires quand même environ 200
personnes qui étaient réunis en présence
également de la reine consort camilla et
du prince william prince de galles donc
prince héritier oui et
cette proclamation qui a été fait par la
suite dans la cour privés du palais
saint-james ne se sera fait devant le
public dans cette fois c'est ça et ça se
fait
dans la cité c'est la partie la plus
vieille de londres c'est ce quartier des
affaires et là
on programmera la population
l'accession officielle voteront du roi
charles et le parlement à la même chose
c'est accepter ce métier à quoi est ce
qu'on peut s'attendre mais c'est
évidemment ça va se faire à abos
peinture au palais de westminster et là
les choses sont peut être sensiblement
la même chose on voit lire la
déclaration et
fort probable qu'il va avoir encore une
fois le lait et bancs du parlement avant
faire vont crier 3 hourra pour cette
annonce
et on fera le tour du royaume uni par la
suite pour aller faire cette
proclamation est vraiment partout seront
dans l'ailé les capitales les trois
autres
composants du royaume vous devez parler
du volet
émotif très
émouvant pour le roi aujourd'hui ans de
vivre cette proclamation officielle
d'être donc les trônes ise roi de façon
officielle plus tendres vivent le deuil
de sa mère il ya moins de jours
exactement et on l'a vu même dans ceux
dans le court discours qu'il a fait lors
de sa proclamation
il a de nouveau rendu hommage à sa mère
et il le préciser de nouveau qu'il
voulait poursuivre ce qu'il est ce que
sa mère avait commencé et qu'il dédiait
sa vie lui aussi
pour de sa vie de service et que le
prince
william était pour évidemment le nouveau
prince de galles il ya un an son taux
auquel on grise pour ce qui pouvait
croire qu'elle ait abdiqué
éventuellement
non je pense que c'est dans notre façon
les comme je disais les plus toniques
cdc des gens qui sont extrêmement
traditionalistes donc de sauter comme ça
de sauter une étape si je peux dire ce
n'est pas dans leurs façons de faire et
le prêcheur toute sa vie il la pensée à
se préparer à ce rôle donc que après ça
qu'ils ne puissent pas vraiment
accomplir ce qui les projets les parce
que lui aussi je suis certain que ça va
continuer mais en même temps ça va
changer et que là lui qui a eu sa
période pour
vraiment le faire sa marque
ici aussi beau être un roi de transition
à 73,1 bon on peut lui donner peut-être
est en train de donner mais quand même
c'est beaucoup plus court que la reine
il y avait donc il sait très bien que
les les grands changements qui vont
vouloir apporter ça va être plutôt
mettre la table pour le prochain roi
donc il est conscient de ça mais en même
temps je suis certaine qu'ils vont
laisser sa marque à sa façon dans les
dernières décennies on a vu un prince
charles prince qu'il était à l'époque
s'impliquer beaucoup dans des oeuvres
caritatives s impliquer au nom de de
l'environnement aussi pour les
changements climatiques et qu'il avait
d'ailleurs lancé une chaîne de
télévision l'année dernière et en un an
en septembre
on l'a vu aussi se porter à la défense
des peuples autochtones est ce que vous
vous attendez à ce qu'il continue quand
même une certaine défense certains
combats où il va devoir vraiment
respecté un grand de voir de raison ça
vous savez difficile de vraiment
continuer comme il le faisait avant il
va falloir que ce serait beaucoup plus
restreint dans ce qu'il va dire mais
comme vous l'avez dit eux-mêmes lui dans
son discours d'hier il le spécifie que
le prune strasse qu'ils avaient créées
dans les halles en 1977 lors du jubilé
d'argent de sa mère
c'est une organisation qui
qui est des jeunes à se lancer en
affaires a créé 2
ça d'aider les jeunes pour toutes sortes
de projets et ça suscite ensuite encore
en place alors là maintenant
évidemment il va pas ils ne pourront
plus être aussi actif dans ce projet là
qu'il l'était avant mais bon ils le
prennent cela sera certainement content
de lui mais ce sera pour lui qui va
vraiment le
supporter comme il le faisait avant mais
je sais une chose qu'il a fait il a
aussi créé
une ferme expérimentale chez lui sa
maison de campagne donc là aussi cette
résidence de highgrove les jardins camp
quand il a acheté la maison la corde au
début des années 80 c'était vraiment pas
il n'y avait même pas de légèreté de
sites à fort mal rien d'organisé
maintenant
il y a
trouvé une équipe de d'agriculteurs pour
l'aider à créer des produits bio qui
sont vendus sur le marché et
mais là encore ça ça va être ça va être
fort probable donner à quelqu'un d'autre
pour poursuivre cette activité là mais
lui ne sera plus impliqué directement et
ses grandes positions sur
l'environnement les changements
climatiques les peuples autochtones
il va continuer à s'y intéresser mais
d'une façon beaucoup plus réservé que il
le faisait jusqu'à maintenant c'est
quand même dommage parce qu'il a une
excellente plateforme pour éviter ce
message-là benjamin des changements pour
les champs pour l'environnement mais le
roi doit être au dessus de ça parce que
c'est vraiment le gouvernement qui
gouverne qui décident des politiques lui
son violent droit de conseillers de
prévenir
de faire remarquer que obs ya peut-être
un danger ici et là mais il ne peut pas
vraiment
dire vraiment ce qu'il pense et c'est
certain que quand à chaque année à noël
y lire le discours de noël du roi mais
lent qu'à se taire comme un résumé des
activités de l'année sans prendre des
positions vraiment
précise l'eau sur des thèmes bien
arrêtées est-ce qu'elle envoie retourner
parlé avec notre collaboratrice spéciale
qui est à londres marie bihan marie le
conseil d'accession a reconnu ce matin
son nouveau souverain le roi charles iii
et avait camilla la reine consort qui
étaient là également avec lui et puis le
prince william la programmation qui a
été lu par l'as fait publiquement dans
cette cour privée du palais saint james
j'ai mari j'imagine que vous avez accès
à ces images en direct et devant en
mesure de nous décrire ce à quoi on
assiste présentement et quelles sont les
prochaines étapes
là les images proviennent du royal
exchange donc du coeur de la city de
londres qui est le quartier financier de
londres mais qui est aussi la partie la
plus vieille de la ville de londres et
il ya effectivement de nombreux soldats
et des représentants de la couronne qui
sont là pour la proclamation aux peuples
de de charles iii en tant que roi
d'angleterre c'est une cérémonie qui est
extrêmement vieille qui a vraiment à des
centaines d'années et qui se fait
effectivement là parce que normalement
la proclamation au balcon de saint james
n'est pas spécialement public dans le
sens où c'est la première fois que les
caméras ont été invités à au sein du
conseil de la session mais aussi sur le
balcon de saint james et pour cette
programmation officielle là ce sont tous
les dignitaires de la city qu'on peut
voir avec l'europe d'hermine avec tout
vraiment tout leur attirail
cérémoniel qui sont là pour assister à
la proclamation de ceux de ce nouveau
s'ouvre à c'est aussi une manière bien
sûr de montrer une forme d'allégeance au
souverain on sait que londres dans
l'histoire a souvent provoqué beaucoup
de soucis aux souverains quand il avait
des pouvoirs politiques donc c'était
important qu'ils montrent cette
allégeance au début au début du règne là
maintenant évidemment c'est plus pour
les traditions et un petit peu le
folklore et on peut voir effectivement
que les héros ont tous sur leur poitrine
le
ainsi faire c'est à dire un monogramme
et si je vois bien je crois qu'il y a
effectivement marqué c'est trois aires
qui serait donc carolus trois rois donc
roi charles iii qui si c'est bien le cas
donc pourrait remplacer le monogramme de
la reine elizabeth ii à dombasle je suis
trompé je vois sur vos sur vos écrans
qu'en fait on a toujours sur la poitrine
oui c'est toujours le
programme d'elizabeth ii e2r donc
elisabeth reggina ce sera changer
éventuellement là on peut s'attendre
effectivement charles iii qui a été
reconnu par le conseil ce matin
proclamation qui sera lu en public et
par la suite j'en parlais avec sl
boutique est avec moi en studio il y
aura cette reconnaissance par le
parlement c'est exact
après utilement ce sera en deuxième
partie de journée le parlement va prêter
allégeance en tant que parent léman
parlement au nouveau souverain alors il
ya une séparation stricte évidemment
désormais de pouvoirs exécutifs et des
pouvoirs parlementaires et les pouvoirs
royaux mais le
symboliquement le parlement prête rend
hommage au roi après chaque député
pourra faire une déclaration personnelle
et solennel mais ça n'est pas
obligatoire il ya 650 députés donc on
pourrait être là pour longtemps si tous
le faisait mais c'est effectivement une
étape importante puisque le roi doit
proclamer signé chacune des lois qui qui
sont décidées par le parlement c'est à
dire qu'une fois que la loi a été
imprimé sur papier officiel est bien le
roi doit écrire le roi le veut en ancien
français jusqu'à présent c'était la
reine le veut évidemment là ce sera le
roi le veut c'est un pouvoir très
important qu'à le roi même si depuis
l'aréna au xviiie siècle aucun souverain
n'a refusé de signer de loi donc là
encore ce sera encore de la tradition
quelque chose qui est évident on ne
s'attend pas à ce qu'il y ait de
rebondissements là dessus mais c'est
justement important quand même de
montrer symboliquement les bonnes
relations entre le roi et son parlement
c'est le jour
d'une série de dix 10 jours pour les
funérailles de la reine de fil annonce
de son décès beaucoup de monde au palais
de buckingham et encore foule ce matin
et on peut s'attendre j'imagine à ce que
cette foule prennent de l'ampleur au
cours des prochains jours aussi en vue
des funérailles
écoutez c'est possible les gens surtout
pendant ce week-end quand ils ne
travaillent pas ou on vouloir
effectivement être présents devant cet
endroit historique après ce qui va se
passer c'est que donc la leur
aujourd'hui c'est la journée du nouveau
roi demain ce sera à nouveau et
d'ailleurs c'est symbolisée par le fait
que les drapeaux ne sont plus à mi-mât
ils sont maintenant en haut des mâts à
nouveau pour célébrer le nouveau règne
demain à midi quand il y aura les
proclamations les trois autres nations
constitutives du royaume uni c'est à
dire au pays de galles en écosse et en
irlande du nord ce sera à midi heure
locale les drapeaux vont à nouveau être
descendus à mi-mât parce qu'on revient
on reviendra en période de deuil et le
cercueil de la reine devrait quitter la
salle de bal où il est exposé en ce
moment au château de balmoral là où elle
est décédée pour aller jusqu'au
palais de holyrood qui est une demeure
officielle puisque le moral est morose
il y aura une cérémonie pour
effectivement amis messe en la
cathédrale saint gilles à edimbourg
avant que mardi a priori la confirmation
doit encore être donné par
par le palais le cercueil de l'art elle
soit amenée jusqu'à londres et allons
enfants dans le monde trois jours les
peut-être même plus et britanniques pour
venir se recueillir devant le crb besoin
de 3 heures sur 24 avant les funérailles
qui devrait être encore une fois on
attend la confirmation lundi et de toute
façon ce jour sur un jour chômé un jour
de congé entre guillemets pour les
britanniques jour des funérailles ou et
jours fériés le 19 septembre prochain
pour les funérailles j'ai bien
l'impression que cette présentation
publique commence avec les trompettistes
convient d'entendre mairie bihan je
remercie d'abord été avec nous ce matin
la voix collaboré à l'émission d'avoir
suivi cette proclamation du roi en
direct avec nous merci beaucoup marie
avec l'usure monsieur vous envoie
6h52 donc cette cérémonie de la
proclamation du roi qui se poursuit
qu'on suit depuis 5 heures ce matin avec
l'analyste en monarchie britannique
estelle les boîtiers qui est toujours à
mes côtés en studio donc encore un peu
de mouvement on s'avance de plus en plus
de minute en minute vers cette
proclamation publique estelle exactement
c'est on voit leur derrière
ce groupe ii de chevalier le hamas qui
est porté par
un membre jeu de je pourrais pas vous
dire s'ils demandent au gouvernement par
exemple je puis tente de le voir
suffisamment mais enfin et là ça avec la
ces instruments là on va pouvoir
commencer l'asim la cérémonie comme tel
de la proclamation au public
ses traits c'est beaucoup de ces de la
tradition si ce sont tous des et autres
fois dans l'histoire c'est important
que ces événements-là se déroule de
cette façon là parce que les moyens de
communication n'étaient pas ce qu'ils
sont aujourd'hui
donc on est seulement à remonter
sentence en 125 ans il y avait même pas
de téléphone donc et les gens pour
connaître ce qui se passait dans le pays
et ça prenait ces gens là qu'elle est
dedans de place en place programmée et
évidemment c'est ce qu'on voit c'est
aussi les gens portaient les habits de
l'époque donc on a gardé cette tradition
là on a vu tantôt un certain nombre de
soldats avec des halles balcer de
l'époque saut presque du moyen-âge ou un
peu plus le temps modernes on a bon
service et ses symboles qu'on voit de
nos jours uniquement dans les films dans
l'es6 et vous bien son ballon mais
puisqu'elle des cérémonies à la tour de
loin de répétition mais au-delà de ça
alors ça c'est que autrefois il y avait
pas les moyens comme qu'elles sont que
nous avons mais le pays décidé de
conserver toute cette tradition là pour
ça ajoute
s'ajoute un pur à la signification de
l'événement qui fait en sorte que le
lieu plus de doute possible
c'est le roi
là présentement c'est schalke nommé roi
et ya pas de doute c'est vraiment ça que
celle qui a été déclarée et on procède
là avec tous les symboles royaux pour
vraiment à établir ce fait et cette
phrase me revient en tête qui a été
proclamé un peu plus tôt au palais saint
james avec le conseil donc le conseil
privé qui a procédé à cette proclamation
en dix ans on a plus qu'un seul roi on a
un seul roi oui pour marquer le passage
c'est ça et puis tout comme les tribunes
de corrèze ce sable ça remonte à 260 et
c'était la façon dont le roi de vraiment
montrer c'est qui nos soldats par
rapport à ceux de l'ennemi alors ce sont
tous de traditions qui se répète
aujourd'hui c'est c'est folklorique mais
son recul d'antin c'était nécessaire
pour vous prier marquez qui était qui et
qu'est ce que ça représentait on sent
quand même qu'un attachement très fort
avec tout le public qui s'est déplacé
pour y assister ça c'est certain les
gens aiment encore tout ce décorum même
si c'est une autre époque
alors qu'on regarde toujours ces images
on dirait que l'on parlait de
l'attachement et des britanniques oui
une partie de la population parce que
vous croyez que c'est quand même un
sentiment généralisé envers la monarchie
en grande bretagne
bon an mal an les les
excuses et justement le terme anglais en
tête mais quand on fait jour dans
l'instant ben voila merci
ça reste que la monarchie a toujours le
la cote c'est toujours autour de 70 75 %
que les gens sont en faveur
de la monarchie évidemment avec un
nouveau ring les prochains sondages vont
peut-être
ils vont changer ça va peut-être baissé
ça va peut-être encore monter puisque
l'eau avec l'arrivée de deux nouveaux
rois les gens sur wii les gens vont
espérer
des choses différentes c'est certain que
le roi charles vouloir
accomplir certains projets qui sont
différents de ce que sa mère faisait
donc ça va permettre les sondages dont
on va voir dans quelques mois comment
les gens réagissent ce nouveau règne
mais je pense bien que savoure toujours
resté à peu près 70 75 % que les gens
les britanniques sont en faveur de
conserver parce que la famille royale ça
fait partie ça fait partie de la la
c'est un membre de leur famille qui est
décédé donc c'est pour ça qu'on sent
toute cette salle une idée cette
tristesse mais maintenant
avec l'arrivée de deux nouveaux rois et
aussi
le plaisir d'avoir un nouveau roi de on
le connaît et puis mais ça reste que on
vient de perdre quelques dans notre
famille alors le sentiment fort
est ce que vous sentez que charles iii
va véritablement vouloir faire sa marque
de façon très importante où il va
vouloir suivre les pas de sa mère il va
suivre les pas de sa main mais va aussi
vouloir faire sa marque
évidemment ici que moins de temps que l
mais en même temps
ils vont vouloir se sont réjouis s'est
distingué que son règlement
ce n est un tout je crois que il va
vouloir que le commonwealth
se soient modifiées retrouvent soit mis
à jour parce que
l'on fonctionne d'une certaine façon
mais lui il veut que ce soit révisé vaut
mieux refléter ce que chaque pays qui
ont scandé membres
représentent donc je pense je crois que
l'ouverture se gênent oui il veut il le
prince william aussi il veut que et ils
disent que si les pays ne veulent plus
être
voyous payés avec ses 59 minutes on ne
glisse à l'oreille que cette
proclamation publique commence on va
l'écouter en direct
[Musique]
et
considérant qu'il a plu à dieu tout
puissant d'appeler à sa miséricorde
notre regretté souveraine la reine
elizabeth 2 ou bien heureux et glorieuse
mémoire par le décès de laquelle la
couronne du royaume unis de la grande
bretagne de l'irlande du nord revient
exclusivement légitimement au prince
charles-philippe artur jorge
par conséquent nous les lords spirituel
et temporel de ce royaume les membres de
la chambre des communes ainsi que les
autres membres du conseil privé de sa
défunte majesté et les représentants des
territoires et royaume les âges des
échevins les citoyens de l'autre et
autres faisons maintenant par la
présence d'une seule voix et de ce
consentement de parler de cas déclarés
proclame que le prince charles philippe
artur jorge et maintenant par l'amant de
notre défunt de souveraine d'heureuse
mémoire est devenu notre solide légitime
seigneur charles iii par la grâce de
dieu du royaume-uni de l'irlande du nord
et ses autres royaumes et territoires
roy chef du commonwealth des penseurs de
la foi auquel nous reconnaissons tout
notre foi et obéissance avec une
inflexion priant du parc il y rois et
les reines l'irene règne de tenir sa
majesté en lui accordant de l'ong
heureuse année de règne sur nous
proclamée au palais saint james en ce
dixième jour de l'an de grâce
comme évoqué
mais bon pas
[Musique]
là
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
petit
richmond c
-b
hep hep
québec
[Applaudissements]
màj
le reste est aboutie qui est toujours
avec moi analystes de la monarchie
britannique cérémonie publique qui vient
d'avoir lieu donc on a proclamé au
peuple le fait que charleroi est
officiellement souverain maintenant dans
le pays il est le seul souverain du pays
donc oui ça a été fait et comme on
l'entend dû à la fin
le peuple a crié 3 aura pour cette
annonce et là on voit les dignitaires
qui rit qui rentrent
à la cité de l'ombre c'est c'est plus ou
moins comme et
les membres de
deux se regroupent al de la vie privée
non c'est l'ancienne cité de londres
c'était c'est le quartier financier donc
lyon lyon dès
la vieille ville de londres au sein d'un
corps de deux personnes qui cassent et
ça dit il de telles cérémonies donc
c'est tout convoi et parce qu'autrefois
c'était vraiment ce coeur de londres
était
souvent à lui pas le poser mais contre
l'élément de la famille alors il ya eu
tout un regroupement pour s'assurer que
eux aussi on lit on les regroupe et on
s'assure de leur c'est pour ça que cette
proclamation là à cet endroit là c'est
qu'on veut s'assurer de leur fidélité de
leurs allégeances surtout donc
aujourd'hui dans le quartier financier
de londres il y aura une autre
proclamation qui va se faire
éventuellement un après-midi au au
parlement oui donc pour officialiser le
fait que charles et roy alors qu'il
était depuis l'instant où sa mère est
décédée
oui mais l'anc en cela cette preuve là
cette proclamation
c'est
d'aider cérémonie qui viennent d'un
autre temps mais que la tradition ont
voulu conserver pour ajouter
le poids vraiment montrer que c'est
vraiment cette personne qui dorénavant
assure
qui devient le souverain du mais elle
risque de passage sur la tradition c'est
la tradition c'est certain que comme on
le dit charles devenu roi à l'instant où
la reine elizabeth est décédé mais tout
ce protocole la cd cérémonie qui date de
notre part mais qui la tradition veut
que on l'est on les fasse en car pour
bien montrer que dorénavant le roi si
cette personne ne la servent aussi merci
infiniment d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin pendant ces deux dernières heures
à suivre en direct cette cérémonie
protocolaire la proclamation publique de
ce nouveau roi on va s'en souvenir
longtemps c'est un moment marquant dans
l'histoire et dans nos vies est
également merci beaucoup et elles m'ont
fait plaisir je vais retourner en direct
à londres pour parler avec catherine
gauthier qui est tout près du palais de
buckingham si je ne m'abuse catherine là
où il ya certainement encore toute une
foule qui souhaitent le voir le nouveau
roi passé je vous disais tout à l'heure
on devait quitter le palais saint-james
pour faire pour aller au client et à peu
près marche de shit minutes en temps
normal car les lieux rien de grave au
taux d'aujourd'hui il ya vous parlez de
marque historique et bien les
britanniques vivent un moment historique
ils font du très très très nombreux
autour du carré saint jean et autres de
bocognano d'ipo entendre cette première
proclamation un peu plus tôt aujourd'hui
pour rendre officielle a avancé al
atassi ont finalement que le roi charles
ii iii et maintenant le roi de grande
bretagne alors on n'a pas pu prendre à
la position caméra à temps pour pouvoir
vous parler imaginer tellement il ya des
rues qui sont bloqués dans ce cas il ya
plusieurs personnes qui sont massés
autour des deux palais et qui fouette
apercevoir justement la voiture qui
arrêtera le roi charles iii jusqu'à vos
kenyan pour les prochaines rencontres
qui vont céder aujourd'hui alors oui un
moment historique
retransmis pour la première fois la
télévision donc c'était la première fois
que bien dix ans voyez vous y entendez
cet événement important il son grand
voisin alors que roy attend après la
parole également un peu plus tôt
catherine le sport
oui en bonne entente si vous voulez tout
d'abord d'un parti de la proclamation
qui s'est tenu dans la cour intérieure
du balcon en fait ce qui d'ailleurs le
plus vieux palais de londres et ses lacs
qu'on fait toute l'administration qui
vous voulez de la famille royale avant
les royautés les rois les reines
maintenant on a des parkings en place
officiellement mais quand même c'est un
lieu
de six
le roi charles iii très conscient des
responsabilités qui lui incombent menin
et qui a pris quand même le temps de
remercier une fois de plus sa mère et de
lui rendre hommage le day 2 avec 2 se
poursuit un bouquet n'y sommes pas là
sans avec la suite du protocole
aujourd'hui pour les prochains jours
catherine oui je voudrais sur notre
trajet en fait
2 ou là encore aujourd'hui ça poursuit
les uns ce recueil
des gens de tous âges et des acquis le
font de façon très silencieux de strates
ans qu'est ce qu'on voit aussi au palais
beau client et ce qu'on voit aussi en
écosse parce que la dépouille de la
reine caroline est encore atteindre
orale long cours des prochaines heures
on va savoir véritablement à quel moment
seront célébrées cette prime de ciel on
sait que ce sera décrété jour férié
si en grande bretagne
donc on ne sait pas à quel moment se
prétendent or la date et de l'heure
concentre là dessus tout un processus on
va ramener la dépouille afin qu'il va
avoir un père aimant et religieux dans
les coffres on va ensuite ramené la
dépôt de la reine à l'ombre chapelle
ardente à vos clients pour les fausses
cortège qui va à la dépouille de la
reine je tiens mais ce n'est que al oula
il y aura s'appelle ardente ouverte au
public et leur on risque de voir encore
une fois beaucoup beaucoup de
britanniques et deux ans venus de
partout dans le monde pour aller lui
rendre hommage et ensuite les
funérailles qui se tiendra à l'abbaye de
wasyl de donc au cours des procès du
jour mais aujourd'hui on devrait être
fixé pour les dates exactes et comment
tout ça va se passer autour de vos
kenyan palace je peux vous dire qu'ils
encore recueillement la reine qui a fait
remarquer il a dégénéré oui énormément
d'émotion à venir encore au cours des
des prochaines journées à catherine
gauthier et puis cette acclamation du
nouveau roi aujourd'hui en finalement
c'est vraiment la journée de charles iii
aujourd'hui qu'on célèbre aujourd'hui en
grande bretagne oui on est là pour vous
on va essayer de déplacer plus près de
nos clients parce que le sable le roi
charles x pas y retourner aujourd'hui il
va rencontrer l'archevêque
il va rencontrer ou qui encore une fois
la première ministre turc des membres du
cabinet oki donc vraiment journée de
travail c'est la fin d'une ère le début
d'une nouvelle ère pour ça et faire avec
une boîte à lumière revenez nous voir au
cours de l'émission avec plaisir
catherine gaud tiers du réseau landes
merci beaucoup on voit
donc ça fait un peu plus de deux ans
maintenant deux ans 15 minutes construit
cette cérémonie qui se déroulait du côté
de londres au palais saint james pour
procéder à cette acclamation officielle
à cette proclamation officielle des
jésus roi charles iii pendant ce temps
là il ya beaucoup de mouvements à
l'international en ukraine l'armée et
craignant qui continue son avancée dans
l'est du pays et ce sont deux mille
kilomètres carrés qui auraient été
libérés depuis quelques jours depuis le
1er septembre dernier j'en parle avec
notre envoyé spécial en ukraine tamar
altérer ce qu à tamara c'est un tournant
majeur pour les deux parties parlez nous
de cette avance est là quel point elle
pourrait être décisive
elle est très certainement décisive va
falloir voir jusqu'où l'armée
ukrainienne avance mais je voudrais
qu'elle est surtout une surprise
savait hier
volodymyr zelensky dans son message
quotidien a dit des gens note des
avancées extraordinaires on ne récupère
et mille kilomètres carrés depuis le 1er
septembre
ça c'était il ya même pas de 12 heures
aujourd'hui quand on regarde la carte je
sais pas si vous l'avez reçu mai